I'm an old man now I'm getting older by
the minute and so I'm old enough to
remember when showing up and making a
giant nuisance of yourself at a capital
was called a coup d'etat an Insurrection
treason sort of thing where you need to
be arrested and thrown in solitary
confinement but turns out that's that's
only the case when it's conservatives
who show up to the Capitol when it is
leftists who show up to the Capitol that
is a wonderful thing and you saw that
this week the trans lives matter
demonstrators occupied the Oklahoma
Capitol Building they occupied it to
protest republican-backed bills that
would ban tranzing the kids
it would ban sex change operations for
people under the age of 26. the argument
being that people's brains aren't fully
developed until they're 25 so you're
going to ban those surgeries until the
brains are developed I think they should
be banned for everybody